انطباعك الممتاز مضمون
قليلا هي
donde لا يتدخل في ما ذهبوا
قلت أنه يمكنك الوقوف
هنا المنتجات
يصبح أكثر سلاسة مما هو عليه في السيارة
هنا
لدينا طابعة في الحظيرة لمدة شهر ، لكن
وثم
الحفلة الموسيقية ستقام
خاصتي هنا بخصوصiversido gudovich وجميع
القرم
رتب هناك
بناة الطرق الطوابق الخاصة 11 هو
بالطريقة المثالية هنا 17
نقاط
عام عام
[تصفيق]
ستذهب الشاحنات في يونيو
بطل
لكنه هو نفسه مستعد بشكل أفضل للشاطئ
الاستعداد للشحن
كل شيء جاهز بشكل جيد هنا طريقة واحدة تمامًا
جاهز الآن لنقل البضائع
2 فعالة لا تزال بحاجة إلى الصمود
القناع جاهز
في النفق كل شيء جاهز بينهما
يريد الناس حقًا في الوقت الحالي وما بعده
عطلة رأس السنة الجديدة إعادة شحن القطارات
في مكان ما حوالي 73 75 في المائة
عالية جدا من الضروري
بوتين نفسه على استعداد لطلب الشاطئ
كل شيء نقل البضائع جاهز بشكل جيد هنا
طريقة واحدة جاهزة تمامًا الآن
الشحن 2 مقسم نحتاج
لا يزال يتقيأ على الجسر كل ما في
النفق بينهما جاهز فارغ
تنتفخ من التوازن ونحن الآن
تثبيت جميع الأتمتة الآن
حظر نظام التحكم
تماما نذهب على الإشارات هم أنفسهم
تبطئ وبالتالي
إبطاء البحث أو العكس بالعكس
لذلك ستختار الوقت على الجانب الآخر
نهج ، ما زلنا بحاجة إلى إنهاء الأتمتة
تم تركيبه وترك التكليف
العمل بين جزء من العمل
نازارينكو
حتى نهاية شهر فبراير في بداية شهر مارس
لهم للحصول على غيض من الاسم
سيكون تعديل الجهاز بالضبط التعديل
أسئلة التشغيل الآلي لجزء القمر
ذات الصلة بأمن النقل
فحص قطارات الشحن من
السكك الحديدية الروسية من هناك هم هناك
الحاجز جاهز من جانب شبه جزيرة القرم
نقطة تفتيش أمنية طلبناها أيضًا
عليك أن تنقلنا للسماح لنا
نقل الموعد النهائي إلى 1 يوليو
كم عدد الأشياء التي يجب القيام بها هنا على الجسر جميعًا
نظام نقل جاهز
الأمن هنا ترى الكاميرا
انذار كل عمل وبالطبع
سؤال ضخم هنا نحن اليوم أيضًا
ناقشت إذا كان ذلك ممكنا
سوف أقدم تقريرا بمزيد من التفصيل عن هذا الجزء
نهج السكة الحديد الذي
الجانبين هناك هم
هو مكهرب ذلك الجزء منها
الجسر نفسه سيكون جميع الرهون العقارية
كهربة تحت أعمدة الكهرباء
بالطريقة نفسها تمامًا مثل النهج مع
الجانبين هنا إلى باغيروف 18 كيلومترا
نهج القرم ولكن أبعد من باجيروفو
نعم dzhankoe لا يوجد كهربة
أوكرانيا ولم تفعل ذلك قط
مخطط ولم يكن هناك كهربة
من dzhankoy إلى سيمفيروبول في اليوم التالي
قسم مكهرب به
التيار المباشر هو تقنية قديمة
الذي لا يستخدم أبدًا تقريبًا.
اتضح أن لدينا ثلاث قطع أراضي في شبه جزيرة القرم
منفصلة التي تحتاج إلى مزامنتها
الآن نحن على وجه الخصوص لا نخسر
حان الوقت لتغيير القاطرة في شبه جزيرة القرم نحن
شراء قاطرات ديزل حديثة جديدة
صنبور 70 b.s. إنه جيد لأنه ليس كذلك
يحرق شبكة جهات الاتصال عندما تنخفض
لها ولكن لا يزال عندما نفهم ذلك
القرم هو عرضنا
لا يهتمون بقيادة قاطرات الديزل
بطريقة ما الدخان ليس هو الأكثر ملاءمة
حتى الكهرباء والجسر والنهج
وموقع dzhankoy أمر لا بد منه بالنسبة لنا
يجب أن نوفر لسنتطلب المشاكل
نيكولاس من القوزاق لدعمنا و
تحولت على جهاز الكمبيوتر مغطاة قريبا جدا
التكاليف
يكهرب نعم جون بنفسي
ثمان وثمانية وثلاثين جيدا
هناك 5 محطات فرعية هذا مكتمل
شبكة الاتصال
وتبعا لذلك تحدث اليوم مع
سيرجي فاليك من الخيار حول الجهاز
هناك قدر هائل من الحماية المتحركة
المعابر على الطريق ونحن نخشى ذلك
زيادة في وتيرة القطارات من قبل
حركة المرور
الحادث هناك تتحرك حتى
أحسنت دعنا نذهب
تكلم الربوبية
وفاز للمرة الأولى
80 لكل 100 كيلومتر هو رقم قياسي
نحن الآن نتحرك بسرعة مماثلة
90 100 كيلومتر فماذا يمكن أن أقول
جيد فاز بالطبع يناسب نفسك
لا يزال هنا في هذه السنوات الأربع فتحت
الحركة في 18 مايو كاتيوشا مينت
اليوم نفتح الحركة
رسميًا في وقت لاحق وصحي كل شيء
مساهمة فريق ضخم نما
حجم موستوتريست جميع القادة
شركة واحدة 2 3 كل ما تريد و
الشباب هنا معنا بالغراء
مدير لك تلك العين الغربية
فلاديمير شباب النخبة بالطبع
سأقول بضع كلمات من فضلك منا
يصبح
لا تمانع وهم على مقدم الرعاية
كان البناء قبل الأزمة عادلًا
هنا مقاتل واحد ينشر فولغوغراد
روستوفيتس 2 موسكو على وتر يمكنك
تذكر ، وركب ديمتري تينياكوف معك
فيما يتعلق بالسيارة ، تقابلنا منعطف
نيجني نوفغورود في توجلياتي
كانت هذه المدرسة رائعة شكرا لك
ضعنا ، لماذا يوجد 15000 شخص
الذين يعملون هنا لمدة أربع سنوات و
فتاة بالطبع هنا نأمل ذلك
ابحث عن مكان عمل صفحتنا
حتى يتم إرسال الشباب الآن
بالفعل ضبط مناطق أخرى
لذلك هذه المدرسة الكبيرة بالتأكيد
كنا وأظهرنا مهاراتنا
المعرفة ربما يمكن للبلد أن تفتخر بها
المثير للاهتمام هو أننا بشكل عام
بنوا جسراً ، لكنهم أعطوا كل شيء بأيديهم
عمال السكك الحديدية وعمال السكك الحديدية
سوف يقومون بعملهم كما يقولون
لدينا مقاولين من الباطن minin و
المواد المنزلية
التقنيات الحديثة
أريد أن أخبركم بما قمنا به
تذكر طلبك عندما تكون في أستراخان
جئت أبلغت عن البرنامج
الجسور صدرت في مجلس الدولة في الصيف
أنا مستعد لأخبرك بماذا
10 ديسمبر
اسألنا 27770 ألفاً منها
داخل تلك اللعبة هذا الطريق وعرة
الخرسانة وهنا نصف مليون متر مكعب هنا عند
عرافة
في ألفا وديل ري اسأل روثنبرغ
فيلم بوسادا لحوم البقر على أريكة زنبق القيام به
عظم
Aulyaki Fetisa و Jamal
تم إصلاح الاعتداء على الجسر
المشاركة في السكك الحديدية
يمكن تمرير التراكيب بوزن إجمالي يساوي
وبرج هلام
عمل 15 ألف مهندس وعامل
على هذا الرف كل هذا الوقت وانتهى
بدا لي ممكنًا ولكن من أجلنا
بناة
ربما كل واحد منا اليوم
يشهد حدثا تاريخيا
يوم عظيم حقا جزيرة القرم
ترتبط شرايين النقل الموثوق بها
هل فعلت روسيا القارية
بأيديهم أمام سيكون انتصارات جديدة
رفوف جديدة ولكن هذا بالطبع كل من
سوف نتذكرك منا مدى الحياة و واحد
من أهم مواقع البناء ومن أهمها
أشياء مهمة في حياتك تم تصميم الجسر
لقرون 9 زلزال مريض في الواقع
الرقم يمكن أن يميز ذلك ، من حيث المبدأ ، في
منطقة البحر الأسود
مستحيل و
في دلفي غازول ماشا
صعب جيجونج مين هو والبومة
التفاف حول مثل هذا 0 j من تلك إنشاءات
10 خطوات أو مترو على أبرام إلى كيرتش
غزة ألمار تل أبيب هي ريهانا
عندما تأكل النفوس هذا جنون
تغيير الهواء بوتو
نموذج kirsch والجدة olya radio rusi
وحديقة الجندي روزي روسي فلاديمير
بوتين ناجارا يعتبر صب داشا
معدلات المسمار الرصاص الغابات yumon
تؤكد
فلاديمير أوساكا على كروم روسي
هل هي تضع الهواة ناضجة يحصل ذلك
تلك التي لوح بها برج يا الساداتي
دفع انها رصاصة نائب الرئيس في انها 100 هادئة
اضطررت إلى الفئران 90 سأستريح أو
موراتي لولا جاسول موكاب دقيقة سام لكن
تفكيك الحور لكم لنا مون التكبير
من حمصه اول بئر نعمه وانت والي
من تاريخ زر الجوز إنكاتا نقل طارق
الطائرات الفولاذية أسستنا على كذبة
والعمل أكتوبر
ليس لديك منهم على أولكس أربات
تأرجح بوابة الكرة
مليون ما يجب القيام به هو 1 سنة من oriko
bio nano one a scare sharks bqz al kabir
ألدر دافي فارس رسم المحيط
بدون أحذية الكاحل سوف qumo
ايدان
لوبي التبغ سوف يموت
الرياضات الإلكترونية لانا ومن الله في الفندق
أربات الشرع جراد البحر بوش
حتى يون وخز على صورة الحديث
الحمام سيقدر ذلك البنائين وهي أمل
اكوما
وذمة ماهر في مريفة تكون
على الخليج واحد بيري لو كو دي سابليه
تضيء nahaka أنت الدور
كان الطريق واللعنة قبالة أروبا
شفرات لا لا لا لا 100 ر حفرة فقط
البيريه والكمبيوتر الشخصي فقط
الألومنيوم aare تول وتلك الخاصة به n
ايلينا غازيف
bi bia boffin على الأقل rubio malinka
يعجن البرلين
زين المعجل الخلفية لنا وللروح
متعب 0 ذري شكراً للقمو العليا
من السهل تخزين المقال وصيتك
lillah anisin في التقويم الجديد
التقدم المادي لهذا ليفين هوف
أدعو الله فيمو جل erbe سواء كانت أدولف
نهر بيرجيت
مينا لنا النبيذ من هذه الصورة كاترينا
nanhai روسي والاستلقاء على شكران دا منهم
كامبيار قبل الفيلم على وجه الخصوص
وهناك هي حصائر سهلة من هذا على جاجا
انها الشهيرة هناك كل من شيرمان
ضرر البطاقة من ثم تقدير الأسعار
هارب القليل من الإيجار المعطى
صلى
أفضل طريقة لعنة المدار
أزياء ما يسمى. ألبا للسماح بدخول سنوات طويلة
طعام e-100
ألما صلاة لك
سيفاستوبول في كرات موودل خارج الحلبة
مثل قزم 1 يمكن أن تغير كايدا أسلوب هزلي
كلب تواصل يعتقلني نصيبي
إلى يد الزعيم من الألعاب النارية avri و taras
المصابيح و
أنا مثل هذه العلامة التجارية البرلمانية ، وكلاهما يكسب
ميل فولي
أنا مريضة وسأصب نفسي هناك
وعلى أيدي ناقلة ألفا وجوكر ماجادان
السيد سوف يستريح لوجان بن لا ينام
أو حسناء 1 ومودم الياقوت الخاص بنا
تطير بعيدًا في فريقي ، فهي لا تزال تتأرجح يا حبيبي 2
الآس على الخادم sidera من ناحية stickman هناك
الروايات المخملية arishka نحن نستحق كل هذا العناء
انترلوك قطر انا من الهوائيات وهنا
سأضع أو سانت بطرسبرغ
حصة الخريف حتى الطابق السفلي
[تصفيق]
نشأت بسبب
لكن هدأ نفسك
آرثر باجا الغول الناس على نموذج فالا
هناك تداول هذه التركيبة السكانية من أجل
إذا كان عامل هوائي واحد على الأقل tavria
أراميس كلاهما موديل قطر جورا جو
شجر الحور د منتوس وفيليه كرمل متعفن و
في افلام yashiru qaytar doggystyle and clogs a and
dunphie المونتاج والرومانسية الرسمية
حركات الكرمل وبيتر لها
لينينغراد